avant j'étais médecin samu
là je suis dans l'hélico on s'apprête à
démarrer le patient il est au bout des
tuyaux j'étais très investis battante
perfectionniste ne lâchez rien je
faisais parfois des gars de 72 heures la
fatigue c'est pas un problème quand on
entend sortie samu à un beau shoot
d'adrénaline et zou envolée la fatigue
mon credo il faut pas écouter ma devise
quand on veut on peut je gérais
parfaitement mes émotions coupé sous
cloche
un copain m'avait surnommé josé assumer
fonctionner gérer alors dans le privé
j'avais à coeur d'être une mère
attentive une épouse agréable et ses
appuis une femme soignée tout ça je
disais les magazines féminins
entre deux interventions vacances d'été
nous arrivons ce soir tard dans les
pyrénées demain rando est ce que je suis
en forme pour ça c'est pas un sujet on
part tous le matins on arrive au col
l'orage menace
or dessin tout de suite je suis sans mes
jambes qui tremblent je serre les dents
je suis pas une chose à autun et puis je
vais pas ralentir le groupe est là en
marchant debout ma jambe se cassent
jetons et 4 heures suivantes
douloureuses sous l'orage coincé de
guingois par les sacs à dos dans la
pente
je me sens comme un fétu de paille
ballotté par l'océan premier rapt d'une
prise de conscience alors hélitreuillage
mais là je suis plus dans l'hélico je
suis dans la nacelle qui
et puis opération les sept mois qui
suivent
je dors je dors la nuit je dors la
journée je dors la soirée j'arrive pas à
lire j'arrive pas à réfléchir je suis à
fleur de peau je veux voir personne je
suis sur off mon coeur à mon corps a dit
stop ça suffit on en mai et quelques
autres qui danse mais depuis quand c'est
lui qui décide
non mais c'est ma tête qui décide mon
corps lui il obtempère
je suis complètement désemparé désemparé
par cet épuisement physique émotionnel
intellectuelle cognitifs
à l'époque le burn-out la notion de burn
out est pas encore arrivé jusque chez
nous j'ai un besoin vital de comprendre
c'est alors que la question d'un
thérapeute
qu'est ce qui vous fait plaisir dans la
vie vous ressources me plonge dans un
abîme de perplexité
mais qu'est ce qui me fait plaisir dans
la vie qu'est ce qu'ils meurent souvent
comment je fais ça je ne sais rien et
vous vous savez comment vous faites ce
qui vous ressources qui vous fait du
bien
alors je me fais accompagner qui je suis
vraiment
quel sens à mon travail quelles sont les
motivations profondes qu'elles sont j'ai
envie de donner à ma vie peu à peu je me
retrouve alors j'ai adoré faire du samu
c'était vraiment super mais la relation
c'est important pour moi être en
relation avec les personnes
alors je perds un virage et je deviens
médecins généralistes
en parallèle je me forme parce que ça
m'a aidé alors je me forme à la
psychothérapie par l'image mentale et
des tic auprès des québécois à l'hypnose
ericksonienne aux thérapies
comportementales et cognitives vous
souvenez je suis un peu perfectionniste
mais je me soigne et j'accentue le
virage devient médecin psychothérapeute
et maintenant j'accompagne des personnes
en souffrance
anna que son lumbago cloue au lit
matt hill qui sait plus servir de son
ordinateur
martin qui s'est mis à bégayer arnaud
quitté persuadé qu'il a une maladie
d'alzheimer pierre un homme
habituellement très courtois qu'à
balancer ses dossiers à la tête de son
comité de direction
tous avec un bilan de santé parfait et
un superbe dénis non à burn out pas eu
pas possibles sont des battants et ben
si si si si burn out
ils sont cramés byrne s'est cramé les
québécois dit ne brûlez mais alors c'est
quoi un burn-out
eh ben c'est pas une dépression c'est la
collision entre une personne une
personnalité vous vous souvenez être
réinvesti battante qui s'écoute pas etc
qui fait pas sa chochotte avec son
histoire personnelle
un travail avec ses exigences son
organisation les personnes qu'on y
rencontre
et puis un contexte plus global social
sociétal accélération global la crise et
s'est éteinte cette rencontre entre une
personne un travail et un contexte
l'énergie dépensée est supérieure à
l'énergie restauré il ya déséquilibre de
la balance énergétique de l'individu
comme me disait arnaud c'est comme si je
courais un marathon mais il aurait pas
de ligne d'arrivée je passe pas au
ravitaillement
j'ai vu notre planète elle crie son
désespoir
elle nous montre la voie du
développement durable et bien comme le
désespoir de notre planète le burn out
c'est une réalité comme le réchauffement
climatique
et puis ça se multiplient alors moi je
vous propose au lieu de le subir
alors au risque de vous choquer d'en
faire une opportunité l'opportunité de
prendre conscience qu'on peut faire du
développement durable de notre énergie
personnelle puissions fait pas tout sens
on va sur off notre énergie personnelle
et renouvelables la thérapie que nous
oblige à faire le burn out nous permet
aussi cerise sur le gâteau de mieux
comprendre qu' on est mieux se respecte
et être davantage en accord avec nous
mêmes nos valeurs comme me disait arnaud
si j'avais pas fait un burn-out j'aurais
continue perpétuellement à reproduire
les mêmes schémas ou elliott qui m'a dit
c'est fini je cesse de lutter contre la
personne que je suis alors bien sûr il
est indispensable d'interroger notre
organisation du travail le mode de
management etc
et puis les choix sociétaux sociaux à
l'échelle de la planète et d'agir à ce
niveau là mais chacun nous à notre chère
à l'échelle personnel le burn out qui
nous oblige à faire des thérapies pour
se remettre en question nous permet
d'aller interroger et nos choix nos
besoins le son ce dont on a besoin
alors comment on fait ça bon je vais pas
vous donner toutes les recettes en
quelques minutes mais on va avoir
quelques quelques aperçus le camembert
on dessine un camembert vous pourrez le
faire chez vous si vous voulez qu'elle
tranche vous réservez au travail
alors pas juste le temps que vous y
passer le temps plus j'y pense
la famille les amis et puis le temps
pour vous pour vous que pour vous
laurence qui en burn-out à qui je
propose de faire cet exercice devant le
paperboard me dit le travail la famille
c'est pas facile c'est pas facile parce
que je suis au travail dès fois je pense
à mes enfants mais quand je suis avec
mes enfants je pense à mon travail c'est
pas simple mais en revanche le temps je
passe pour moi c'est très facile
deux heures par mois chez le coiffeur et
en dessinant c'est toute petite tranche
pour elle et s'écroule elle prend
conscience deux heures par mois pour
elle et vous quel ton vous prenez pour
vous comment vous faites ça alors moi
j'ai découvert que le jardinage me vider
la tête en rentrant de mais garde sa mue
en même temps ça me fait travailler mon
perfectionnisme bon vous pouvez regarder
il ya encore un peu de boulot de ce côté
là 1
mais on va se mettre à la permaculture
un peu de désordre organisé ça va mettre
du mouvement le temps qu'on prend pour
se ressourcer pour soi remonte notre
énergie
si on le vit en pleine conscience
ares 1 mais alors c'est quoi la pleine
conscience mais c'est très simple c'est
enfantin et en même temps c'est
compliqué à mettre en application la
pleine conscience c'est vivre les choses
en étant pleinement conscient de l'est
vivent présent à l'instant sans être
dans les regrets du passé si j'avais su
si j'avais vu d'autres parents s'il a
fait d'autres études etc où la critique
de soi des mauvaises comme speaker un
branchement ou l'anticipation de la
catastrophe on n'y arrivera pas on va
pas nous suivre
ça va foirer donc vivre en pleine
conscience
les moments qui nous ressources
alors il ya un autre petit truc pour
faire ça chez sur vous en avez entendu
parler mais je suis sûr aussi vous le
faites pas ou pas tous les jours vous
pouvez le faire tous les jours
maintenant
après le tedx là tous les soirs tous les
soirs vous noté cinq choses positives
vécu dans la journée un dossier terminer
un rire partagé avec quelqu un petit
moment tranquille pour vous si vous en
trouvez pas 5 vérifier si vous n'êtes
pas sur la réserve un côté carburants
alors une autre question est ce que vous
croyez ce que vous pensez être une
personne assure n'est la plupart des
personnes en burn-out vous souvenez cd
battant responsables engagés investi
répondent oui on a affirmé être affirmée
ou assertif sait prendre soin de ses
besoins propres autant que de ceux des
autres alors je vous invite à observer
comment vous vous comportez à l'effet
pas comment vous pensez faire quand vous
faites et puis bien souvent si j'ai les
jambes et là où ton se rend compte que
je prenne beaucoup plus loin des besoins
des autres que des leurs je me souviens
d'un art manager avec une voix
impérieuse
persuadé d'être quelqu'un de très
affirmé et bien en fait en regardant ces
comportements dans son décompte que elle
prenait soin des autres tout le temps
jeu medal que le travail comme à la
maison
prendre soin de ses besoins et légitime
c'est vital
un là j'entends gens qui me dit ouais
votre histoire de besoin là c'est quand
même un peu tarte à la crème 1
ouais non non non non ce pas tarte à la
crème
c'est prendre soin de ses besoins
fondamentaux de nos besoins de sens nous
besoin de valeurs nos besoins de
reconnaissance nos besoins de relations
secure
scène être affirmée s'est toujours fait
ce mot-là être en équilibre
prendre soin des besoins des autres et
de l'autre prendre soin de ses besoins
de ressources mois avant quand j'avais
du temps pour moi mais je prévoyais de
faire plein de choses
bien sûr je vous ai qu'une partie alors
le soir
eh ben au lieu de me féliciter de ce que
j'avais fait plutôt remettre du
carburant dans ma machine eh ben je
regardais ce que j'avais pas fait vous
faites pas ça vous non vous êtes
contents de vous le soir même si vous
n'avez pas tout fait et puis apprendre à
tenir nos frontières vous savez notre
espace personnel là comme seront par
exemple sur lequel je suis notre espace
physique notre espace émotionnel
apprendre à le tenir ça ça prend ça moi
j'ai appris ça en images mentales et
d'éthique ou du parent quand on en a
parlé j'ai dit oh et puis je me suis dit
qu'est ce que je risque à expérimenter
et ben c'est génial
et depuis ça ma compagne en permanence
même devenu un automatisme
c'est quoi la pleine conscience faut
s'entraîner puis après ça on le fait
naturellement et oscar mon formateur
québécois il me disait josé c'est
beaucoup moins coûteux de tenir les gens
à distance que de les sortir de ses
frontières quand ils sont rentrés et
puis tenir ses frontières ça permet de
tenir à distance les personnes toxiques
savez c'est attrayant les personnes
toxiques mais vaut mieux pas s'en
approcher les manipulateurs les
harceleurs les passif agressif on en a
tous dans notre entourage 1 c'est normal
tôt qu'après ce petit florilège de ce
qu'on peut faire alors chaque personne
est unique et chacun a besoin de faire
son travail a soit sur ses croyances ses
choix ses besoins
moi j'ai envie de vous poser une
question une seule si vous chacun
chacune d'entre vous ne prenez pas soin
de vérifier vos indicateurs personnel
vous jauge d'actionner vos freins
abolition de passer à la pompe remettre
du carburant de prendre soin de vos
besoins
qui qu'il fera à votre place
[Applaudissements]